der Anschlag auf die Nord Stream
Pipeline der hat gezeigt wie verwundbar
wir sind wenn es um unsere
Energieversorgung geht riesiges Loch in
der großen Gasleitung in der Nordsee und
niemand hat mitbekommen wer das wann da
reingesprengt hat die Folge die
Bundeswehr die war alarmiert um unsere
kritische Infrastruktur zu schützen vor
Anschlägen und vor einem Angriff der
russischen Armee ja in Estland trainiert
die Bundeswehr ganz genau das jetzt ein
Großmanöver das heißt Baltic Tiger und
da geht es eben um den Schutz unserer
kritischen Infrastrukturen mittendrin
unsere bildreporterin Antonia
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Air Base und Marie Estland die russische
Grenze ist nur 200 km weit entfernt
Putins Kampfjets konnten diese Distanz
nur wenige Minuten überwinden im Moment
trainiert die Bundeswehr nur aber wer
sich hier befindet konnte denken dass
der Krieg schon längst angefangen hat
wir haben die Meldung bekommen dass wir
Feinde in diesem Waldstück haben
daraufhin kam der Befehl an den Zuhörer
dass wir als Tiefe Gruppe hinter den
ersten beiden Gruppen laufen
ja guten Tag
vorne
heißt diese Übung
170 Soldatinnen und Soldaten der
deutschen Luftwaffe und Marine üben hier
wie man sich vor dem russischen Bären
verteidigt verteidigen vor dem Einmarsch
Putins verteidigen vor einer feindlichen
Invasion
wir sprechen ja immer von dem Bereich
den bewirken können also wir haben ja
Bereiche von 1500 Metern Tag nach
Kampffähigkeit beim 40 x 53 GmbH das
schwere Maschinengewehr 12,7 x 99 da
sprechen wir so von 1500 Metern
Minentaucher springen ins eiskalte
Wasser wir Fitness gerade in einem
sprenggebiet der ehesten und wir haben
heute die Möglichkeit mit den
esthetischen Tauchern zusammen ein
unterwassersprengung zu machen
Putins schmutzige Bombe eine Drohung des
Kremmel Tiran auch auf diese schmutzige
Bombe bereiten Sie sich hier vor der
Leopard Kampfpanzer wird nach einer
vermeintlichen Attacke von Soldaten mit
abc-masken von atomaren biologischen und
chemischen Bedrohungen gereinigt
atmen
ein bisschen anstrengend aber besser mit
Maske als ohne immer wieder Kampfjets in
der Luft die Übung der Einheiten eine
Gefahr für Putin der Diktator schickt
seine Spione in die Nähe der Grenze noch
respektiert Putin die nato-grenzen die
Aufklärung der Russen geschieht aus der
Ferne die Inspekteure der Luftwaffe und
der Marine lassen sich nicht
einschüchtern wir zeigen NATO
Territorium das ist die rote Linie wir
werden sehen Zentimeter verteidigen und
hier sollte man nicht rüber treten ich
denke wir haben deutlich gezeigt dass
wir in der Lage sind unsere Partner sehr
schnell zu verstärken und für das Motto
der NATO im
einzustehen einer für alle und alle für
ein Ziel der Übung bautec Tiger ist es
im Ernstfall helfen und Flugplätze gegen
Putins Armee zu verteidigen
das was wir hier auch geübt haben das
trifft natürlich auch für Absicherung
von Flughäfen oder sehhälften in
Deutschland ganz genauso zu
es war ein langer Tag jetzt sitzen wir
wieder im A400 und jetzt geht es zurück
nach Berlin aber zum Abschied habe ich
sogar ein Patch bekommen von Baltic
Tiger
[Musik]